hey das ist Q&A Reportage zum Thema
Pumpe bist aus Limit danke viel mal dass
er mitkommentierten und danke auch für
eure Kritik mit der möchte ich nämlich
gerade anfangen so dabei Deutsch liebt
wenn jemand eine Doku über Fitness macht
wäre es vielleicht gut dass man nicht so
viele Vorurteile hat ganz schlimme dog
über ein sehr interessantes Thema und
freilini schreibt ich finde es gut Dokus
zu produzieren die die Menschen ermutigt
Sport zu treiben diese bewirkt leider
eher das Gegenteil ich hätte mir von der
Reporterin gewünscht dass sie den
Protagonisten mehr zuhört anstatt mit
Vorurteilen um sich zu schlagen und dass
sie sich vielleicht generell etwas mit
Sport auskennt
hey es stimmt ich kann wirklich
vorurteilt bevor ich die Reportage
gemacht habe und dir mache ich wieder
Reportage
das Meer als Reporterin der direct mit
der Haltung des Thema anerkennt das
gehört zum Format und das gehört auch
dazu dass wir euch in meine zacket und
die sich auf weiterentwickeln während
der Reportage und in dem Fall ich
minimalig dann kann Wähler und dem
Rahmen
bevor ich mit ihnen wirklich vorgestellt
dass Bodybuilding Filme mit positive
gestanden wird und doch nicht definitiv
auch dazu erklären ich weiß jetzt das
Bodybuilding elide schafft ist wo
wirklich viel von einem großen Respekt
vor deine zwei dass sie das so
durchziehen dann sind das paar
Kommentare mit der Frage wo denn Frauen
Team ich mag eigentlich eure Dokus
leider entspricht diese Doku nicht dem
was ich erwartet habe die Sache wird
sehr einseitig betrachtet und ist voll
mit Vorurteilen gegenüber dem Kraftsport
keine Frage lautet nur wo waren die
Frauen ist die muskelsucht ein rein
männliches Problem und der Joshua
schreibt finde es etwas einseitig dies
nur auf Männer zu beschränken gibt
heutzutage durchaus viele Frauen die
genau diesen Lifestyle beschreiben hey
viele Dank für Eure Kommentare ich freue
mich immer über konstruktives Feedback
ich habe mich Ideen für Männer
konzentriert weil sie tatsächlich am
meisten von der muskelsucht betroffen
sind Betroffenen
war wenn sie in Spiegel sind sie weniger
als eigentlich Täter ist sie hat viel
Stress wegen Sport und ihre Gedanken
kreisen eigentlich nur nur um Fitness
und um Ernährung aber klar es gibt
natürlich auch Frauen
sich das Thema interessiert
was genau
Musik gemacht und mit trainieren und mit
Fitness der Jonas schrieb also ich bin
jetzt 37 Jahre alt Familienvater und
habe etwa vor einem Jahr begonnen drei
bis fünf Mal in der Woche Krafttraining
zu machen ich bereue rückblickend nicht
schon bereits viel früher damit
angefangen zu haben neben den
gesundheitlichen Vorteilen die sich
darin zeigen das ist so gut wie kaum
mehr Rückenprobleme habe was vorher sehr
häufig vorkam sind auch die optischen
Veränderungen sehr erfreulich und da
gibt sie Frau schrieb dass er sportlich
sechsmal pro Woche ist Fitness er
schreibt nur weil wir jetzt in den 70ern
sind heißt das noch lange nicht dass wir
nur noch auf das Ende warten sollen
weiter so aber alles Gruß aus Neuseeland
auf jeden Fall liebe Grüße zurück und
danke für die Kommentare es freut mich
wirklich sehr dass ihr so gute
Erfahrungen gemacht mit Sport und dass
sie auch weggefunden hat wozu euch passt
dann hätten geschrieben
happy oder krankhaft die Faulheit und
siehe beides schon erlebt und sie haben
mich zu aus mein mindset hat also von
Sport gleich gut aussehen zu Bewegung
gleich Gesundheit Erhaltung des
Bewegungsapparats und wohlfühlen in der
eigenen Haut gewechselt und mit dem kann
ich mich mega gut identifizieren
Sport gemacht ich bin regelmäßiges
Fitness gegangen und ich habe dann aber
gemerkt dass mir das nicht taugt will
ich bin sehr schnell so einen
Leistungsgedanken und dann immer wieder
besser werden und die kann ich
eigentlich mit dem angefangen
ausgeglichen schaffen ich bin in einem
kritischer Wurm mit mir selber und dann
eine aufgehört heute kann ich regelmäßig
gut spazieren und das funktioniert super
für mich aber was für mich gut
funktioniert heißt überhaupt nicht dass
das für andere altlösung ist Christoph
wir essen zu viel was aus meiner
Perspektive keine Überraschung
hinsichtlich dieses Überangebots an
kalorienreichen Lebensmitteln ist daraus
folgt meine Konklusion dass unsere
Gesellschaft der bewegungszwerge ist und
Leistungsdruck im Hobbysport meiner
Meinung nach keine allzu große Relevanz
hat in diesem Sinne trainiert fleißig
weiter und habt Freude an der Bewegung
hey danke dass du deine Gedanken zu der
Reportage und zu der Gesellschaft mit
euch teils trotzdem finde ich es wichtig
dass man über der leistungdruck im Hobby
Sport rettet gerade will rund
einfeuchten vor der Männer im Fitness
und Gesundheit
wie vielen Menschen in der Schweiz an
der muskelsucht leidet geht es leider
nicht aber Schätzungen
haben gemeinsam etwa vier Hirnzellen
altes Vorurteil aber immer noch treffend
hey ich handel wirklich alle als sehr
offen und über leid die Personen
kennengelernt wo einfach eine
Leidenschaft machen könnt und ich finde
es schade dass das alte Vorurteil aber
das immer noch nicht überholt ist
und dann zum Schluss würde ich nur gerne
über Anabolika reden Lilian Rasi schrieb
fitwelity und Anabolika the Widerspruch
voll krank hey danke vielmal fürs
mitkommentiere ich finde es wichtig dass
man eine direktpauschalisiert
wie viel Personen in der Schweiz
Anabolika anwendet gibt es leider nicht
aber so ist medical Forum schätzt dass
es mehr wie 200.000 Personen sind wurde
Image ein performance and handsing Drugs
verwendet
wurden wirklich sehr vielfältig Sie also
für Akne überschrumpfen die Horde bis
sie zu langfristige Niere und lehrreiche
ich wirklich alles dabei
kann mir das war Anabolika anwendet und
was mich erst wie einfach dass man die
Mittel mit wie viel halbwürste dass die
konsumiert werden
und Bodybuilder Anabolika anwendet sind
vielseitig aber Ästhetik spielt sicher
ein großer Rolle ich finde es wichtig
dass man der Gebrauch nicht verurteilt
und wie man den Roland Müller im
Interviews leitet wir suchen alle
irgendwie nach Bestätigung und das Buddy
machen